[Music]
so the last few weeks I've been found a
really fun a rabbit hole I thought I
would share what that is it's all based
on the idea that a1 in spin has two down
beats the play goes down down down down
and I'm clearly in spin at the side so
it makes me a strange pattern one beats
the bottom in one beats it's actually
kind of like the 1/2 of a wide position
if I reverse that it's going to be a
triquetra that points to the side again
it's down and down down down and down
that and the downs are weird places so
what happened was I was playing with
some isolation and what to me was the
original hybrid that Andy Nick Schmidt
showed me Thailand so long ago which is
where the arms move same time you
isolate one of the poise the others and
extension and the arms are in same time
but the player in split time I mean Andy
showed that to me oh did that ever blow
my mind so I was playing with doing a
that on one side so on this side my
right play my orange play is isolating
and switching and practicing the left
boy doing the isolation and then seeing
if I could delete them
like setting one side switching right
isolates left isolates until it becomes
this so it's a I like I mean I'm sure a
bunch of tech people oven oohing this
for a while
something and I toyed with but never
really push through to make it smooth
but super cool feeling and I really like
the way the effect because my hands are
smoothly making a circle while the poi
do split time pattern so I think it's
really super cool and it feels really
amazing
then I'd played a bunch of times of
trying to do triquetra buzzsaw fountain
anti-spin and I would typically do the
something like the right point points up
and left down right up left down right
up that kind of work done right up left
down because that goes well with the
other fountains about sup happens I do
so for instance the 10 pedal would be
the right points up left down right up
left down and 1/8 pedal would be right
up and right down right up and right
down I've such a habit of putting my
points on the Cardinals but then I
realized that if I am doing this pattern
which is really almost very difficult to
do with the pedals at the top and bottom
because the arms get in the way but it's
wonderfully fluid if the pedals are
sides I realize if I just reverse that
so the poi are touching this in points
at the same time so instead of going 1 2
3 4 it's 1 2 3 4 same position I miss
anti spinning on the same rhythm but
each point right atra the right plate I
catch of my orange one points to the
left and my left one points to the right
or that's what I'm trying to do and
awesomely
you can just switch back and forth now I
say that having spent weeks practicing
this a lot to make it work and you know
of course having years of experience
behind that so I don't think it's I'm
not saying it's easy but I am saying it
feels cool and I think it looks pretty
cool I'm gonna have to keep working on
this to make it really silky smooth but
the thing is there's something about the
plane control that this is making me
come back and hone and a certain feeling
I'm getting from this that's really
bringing me back into I don't know it's
sort of Luke Skywalker playing that the
force kind of feeling that play can play
can can do or that can be experienced
through play and I'm really enjoying
that so yeah it's a pretty inspirational
so that's what it is and that's how it
works
but getting there will take time and I
highly recommend starting with more
pedals
so with the right joints up circle and
neck down circle right up circle left
down until you're making ten petals are
really smooth and then to where eight
petals were each making a
for peddled anti-spin and when all of
that is really slick then doing the six
peddled too treacherous and yes you oh
it's so weird you can combine them but
make do another video I've managed to do
that I haven't made it look good yet
equals the Playboy
reporting from Leviathan studio it's so
awesome here we've got the new wood
stove I love it
we're doing a play event here as you
might know starting to tune 15 2019 it's
gonna be great and the details on their
website come play
[Music]